R
EYES.
>> Brian: IS THAT BILL MAHER OR
MARK LEVIN.
BRIT HUME FOX NEWS SENIOR AM
LIST.
BRIT, WHY NOW?
WHY THE CHANGE IN TONE NOW?
>> WELL, I THINK FOR A COUPLE
REASONS.
ONE OF THEM IS DONALD TRUMP WAS
GONE AND TRUMP WAS PARTIAL TO
THIS IDEA.
YOU REMEMBER HE CALLED IT THE
WUHAN VIRUS AND THE CHINESE
VIRUS.
AND SO IT WAS MEANT THAT FOR THE
LEFT HATING HIM AS THEY DID,
THAT THAT IDEA OF THE THING
BEING SOMETHING THAT CHINA WAS
CAUSING CHINA AS A NATION
BECAUSE THAT'S A GOVERNMENT,
OBVIOUSLY A GOVERNMENT
OPERATION, THAT LAB, WAS
ANATHEMA.
PEOPLE HATED THAT IDEA.
SO, WELL, YOU DIDN'T HEAR IT.
AND IT WAS SCOFFED AT.
IT WAS SAID TO HAVE BEEN
DEBUNKED WHICH, OF COURSE, IT
NEVER REALLY HAD.
SO THAT WAS A BIG PIECE OF IT.
AND THE OTHER PIECE OF IT WAS
THAT, YOU KNOW, THERE WAS THIS
ALTERNATIVE THEORY ABOUT, YOU
KNOW, HOW IT MIGRATED FROM BATS
OR PANGOLINS OR WHATEVER TO
HUMAN BEINGS WHICH I GUESS CAN
HAPPEN BUT IT'S NOT -- YOU KNOW,
THE PROBLEM WAS ALWAYS, BRIAN,
THAT THE THEORY THAT IT WAS --
CAME OUT OF THAT LAB WAS
PLAUSIBLE ON ITS FACE BECAUSE
THE LAB WAS THERE AND WORKING ON
DISEASES OF THIS KIND IS WHAT
THEY DID.
SO, FINALLY I THINK, YOU KNOW,
WHEN WE FINALLY HEARD, YOU KNOW
IN THE "WALL STREET JOURNAL,"
FOR EXAMPLE, THE LAB WORKERS WHO
HAD GOTTEN SICK RIGHT ABOUT THE
TIME THIS WAS THE OUTBREAK
BEGAN, IT REACHED A CRITICAL
MASS AND THE TIME HAD COME TO
TAKE IT SERIOUSLY AS PEOPLE ARE
NOW DOING.
>> Brian: REVEALING INTERVIEW
WITH DR. MARC SIEGEL IT LOOKS AS
THOUGH THE FORMER CDC DIRECTOR
SAID THEY WERE PICKED UP NOW AS
THEY LOOK AT SATELLITE IMAGES
AND GET REPORTS THEY ARE SEEING
THIS COULD HAVE EARLY AS
SEPTEMBER WHICH WHY NEW YORK WAS
BLITZED WITH IT FIRST AND WE HAD
NO IDEA WHAT WAS HITTING US AT
THE TIME.
MEANWHILE THE CDC DIRECTOR WENT
ON TO TALK ABOUT THE FOLLOW-UP
INVESTIGATION THAT HE WANTED TO
DO WHEN HE WAS IN OFFICE WHEN
DONALD TRUMP WAS IN POWER AND
WAS UNABLE TO DO BECAUSE HE
FEELS AS THOUGH HE WAS BEING
BLOCKED IN MANY CASES.
HE TALKED ABOUT THE OPTIMISM HE
DOESN'T HAVE THAT THE W.H.O.
WOULD BE LEADING A SECOND
INVESTIGATION.
LISTEN.
>> THERE IS NO DOUBT THAT W.H.O.
WAS HIGHLY COMPROMISED BY CHINA.
AND STILL IS.
I DON'T THINK WE CAN HAVE A
MEANINGFUL TRANSPARENT
INVESTIGATION LED BY W.H.O.
I THINK THEY ARE JUST TOO
COMPROMISED.
>> Brian: THIS IS PRETTY
SENSATIONAL.
WE ARE ABOUT TO HAVE A SECOND
INVESTIGATION AT THE BEHEST OF
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES WHO ASKED HIS
INTELLIGENCE APPARATUS TO DO IT
AS WELL.
THEY HAVE NO ACCESS.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY EXPECT TO
DO.
HE IS SAYING DON'T WORRY ABOUT
IT.
NOTHING IS GOING TO COME OF IT.
>> I THINK HE IS RIGHT ABOUT
THAT.
I THINK IT'S DISMAKING THAT THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION AND THESE
WESTERN LEADERS WHO HAD BEEN
MEETING FOR THE PAST WEEK ALL
WANTED THE W.H.O. TO BE THE LEAD
PARTY IN THE INVESTIGATION.
THE W.H.O. I THINK IS
COMPROMISED.
LOOK BACK TO THE BEGINNING OF
ALL OF THIS FROM THE W.H.O. WAS
PRAISING CHINA FOR NOW
TRANSPARENT IT HAD BEEN.
CHINA HAS BEEN ANYTHING BUT
TRANSPARENT.
THE W.H.O. REALLY HAS NO
CREDIBILITY.
I THINK IT IS DOMINATED BY
CHINA.
AND SO, MY GUESS IS THIS IS
NEVER GOING ANYWHERE.
CHINA IS NOT GOING TO COOPERATE
WITH ANY SERIOUS INVESTIGATION.
IT'S NOT IN THEIR INTEREST, AS
THEY SEE IT, TO DO SO.
SO HERE WE ARE.
I THINK THE SUSPICION NOW THAT
CHINA IS RESPONSIBLE WILL BE
ENHANCED BY ITS CONTINUING
REFUSAL TO COOPERATE.
WHO KNOWS WHAT EVIDENCE HAS
ALREADY BEEN DESTROYED.
HOW MANY PEOPLE WHO MIGHT HAVE
THE ANSWERS HAVE DISAPPEARED AND
SO ON.
SO, IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT I
THINK ANYBODY HAS REASON TO BE
OPTIMISTIC ABOUT.
BRINE BRIAN LET'S CLOSE WITH
THIS, SOMETHING WE CAN CONTROL.
AND WHAT DR. REDFIELD SAID WAS
STRIKING.
HE SAID I EXPECT POLITICIANS TO
BE POLITICAL.
I DIDN'T EXPECT SCIENTISTS.
AND HE FELT AS THOUGH POLITICS
WAS ALL OVER THE POLICY WHEN HE
WAS IN OFFICE.
AND THAT GOES RIGHT BACK TO
ANTHONY FAUCI WHO SEEMINGLY HAS
DISAPPEARED OVER THE LAST WEEK.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON HIS CONCLUSION?
>> WELL, I -- LOOK, I USED TO BE
AND TO SOME EXTENT STILL AM AN
ADMIRER OF DR. FAUCI BUT I THINK
HE HAS MADE A NUMBER OF SERIOUS
MISTAKES IN THIS.
AND I THINK HE HAS I DON'T KNOW
ALONG WHEN HE SHOULD HAVE SPOKEN
THE TRUTH.
LET'S TAKE THE EXAMPLE OF
MASKING, FOR EXAMPLE, IN THE
EARLY GOING, HE SAID PUBLICLY
AND IN AN EMAIL THAT WE HAVE ALL
SEEN, THAT MASKS REALLY ARE NOT
GOING TO PROTECT YOU OF THE KIND
THAT WE ALL HAVE.
YOU KNOW, TALKING ABOUT THE BLUE
ONES WE ALL SEE BECAUSE THEY ARE
THE DROPLETS ARE TOO SMALL, THEY
WILL PENETRATE A MASK.
THEY MIGHT PROTECT YOU FROM SOME
DROPLETS GETTING THROUGH BUT NOT
GIVE YOU THE KIND OF PROTECTION
YOU WANT OR NEED.
I THINK THAT WAS TRUE.
I THINK THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT HE
THINKS.
HE HAS BEEN AROUND A LONG TIME.
MASKS ARE NOTHING NEW.
HE KNOWS ABOUT THEM OR HAD
REASON TO.
AND NOW, LATER, HE CAME ALONG
AND CHANGED HIS MIND COMPLETELY
ABOUT THAT.
SO, WHICH IS IT?
I THINK HE WAS RIGHT THE FIRST
TIME AND I THINK THAT HIS
WOBBLING ON WAVERING ON THAT
ISSUE IS ONE EXAMPLE OF WHY HIS
CREDIBILITY IS NOW FINISHED.
>> Brian: AND HIS REAL REFUSAL
TO THOROUGHLY INVESTIGATE THE
WUHAN LIMPING TO THIS WHOLE
THING STRIKES AT HIS CULPABILITY
AND CAPABILITY.
I'M VERY CURIOUS TO SEE HOW THIS
GOES.
MY HUNCH, I KNOW YOU ADMIRE HIM
BY THE TIME HIS BOOK COMES OUT
IN NOVEMBER HE WILL BE TOTAL